my name's I'm Whistler welcomed by
graphics today the most famous most
quoted and most accurate visionary
prophet of modern times a French doctor
pharmacist Alchemist and practitioner of
the occult who in his lifetime would
advise royalty and who after his death
would never be out of print he is the
protagonist of today's story Michel de
nostradame better known as Nostradamus
obviously there are gonna be some pretty
funky pronunciations in this episode I'm
doing my best
it is what it is there is little we know
with certainty about his life and
exploits but we will trace his career
and look in detail at some of his most
famous prophecies and as it is fitting
for such a mysterious character there is
more to be discovered about Nostradamus
and his prophecies as proven by a recent
finding in the old library of his alma
mater the University of Montpellier a
chapter apparently entirely dedicated to
the end of times from which we have
quoted the early quatrain but more on
that later for the moment let's dive
into Nostradamus formative years
Michele de nostradame was born in song
Remi de Provence southern France either
on the 14th or the 21st of December 1503
Perrins Rennie adds a surah me and her
husband Jean de Nostradamus a grain
dealer and notary Michels grandfather
gigas na was a Jewish doctor and
Kabbalist who had converted to
Catholicism in 1455 and changed the
family name - Nostradamus a means to
avoid discrimination and even
persecution by the Inquisition we don't
know much about Michels childhood except
that he was very bright and that he
advanced quickly through school both of
his grandfather's recognized his
potential for learning and dedicated
themselves to tutoring him his maternal
grandfather Jean tesora me taught him
how to speak and read in Latin Greek
Hebrew as well as the rudiments of
mathematics and while his paternal
granddaughter Cabalists introduced him
to the more esoteric knowledge of
ancient Jewish tradition and the science
of astrology
although this has been disputed it could
explain Nostradamus interest in applying
the study of celestial bodies and how
they could influence him
destiny at the precocious age of 14
Nostradamus I know up to the University
of Avignon to study medicine his studies
were cut short the following year
however because of an outbreak of the
bubonic plague this may have been his
first encounter with the deadly disease
to which he dedicated most of his
medical practice in later years in the
following four years young Michelle
travelled the French countryside
researching herbal remedies and working
as an apothecary in 1522 age 19 he gave
it another go at getting a degree this
time entering the University of
Montpellier at the time regarded as one
of the best for the teaching of medicine
the Faculty was largely composed of
Catholic priests with whom he often
clashed apparently they were dismissive
or even suspicious of his early
astrological knowledge let's not forget
that this was a period of great
religious tension in the French Kingdom
with the Protestant faction of the Hyuga
nose growing in power both in the south
and in the Parisian Court causing the
Catholic establishment to be suspicious
of any heretic believer including those
who had Jewish origins but what
ultimately led to his expulsion from
medical school was a more mundane matter
university officials found out about his
previous trade as an apothecary
something considered a lesser manual
trade and therefore unworthy of that
lofty temple of medical studies that was
Montpellier this approach is consistent
with views of the time in fact even
surgeons were considered manual
labourers and treated as second-class
citizens by medical professionals but
was he actually expelled though after
all surgeons are allowed to attend
lectures in Montpellier even though they
had to buy or even steal their own
corpses if they wanted to practice with
their scalpels and in fact other
accounts state that Michelle de
nostradame did complete his medical
degree in 1525 the same year in which he
changed his last name to the Latin
Nostradamus as was common practice among
intellectuals and academics of the time
but did he actually get that degree
though now according to other accounts
it was during the years 1521 to 1529
that he traveled the countryside
perfecting his herb or remedies and his
apothecary skills during those years
Nostradamus was aged eighteen to twenty
six the age in which one would normally
go to university as mentioned earlier
there is little of certainty in
Nostradamus earlier life but what
matters is that he did acquire medical
knowledge either through study or
through hands-on practice and that he
would use their knowledge against the
bane of his contemporaries the bubonic
plague
[Music]
over the ends of the 1520's and into the
early 1530s Nostradamus married and had
two children he was frequently
travelling however especially around
southern France and Italy treating
victims of the bubonic plague there was
no known treatment at the time for this
infectious disease but Nostradamus had a
stab in developing a healing powder take
one ounce of the sawdust of Cypress
woods as green as you can find six
ounces of Florentine violet root 3
ounces of cloves 3 grams of sweet
calamus and 6 grams of aloes wood so now
you might be wondering or not did it
work well we know that violet root is
still actually used today to treat
coughs and fevers so well actually maybe
yes
although calamus well that's forbidden
in the United States because it's so
incredibly toxic so maybe not but one
Worcester Thomas did get right where the
methods to prevent outbreaks of the
plague effective personal hygiene
removal of infected corpses and fresh
air simple stuff today but actually
pretty revolutionary in 16th century
Europe
thanks to these measures Nostradamus
became a local celebrity in the Provence
region in southern France even receiving
financial support from its citizens ends
in 1531 juices are Skellig a a leading
physician of his time became his patron
and invited him to work with him in
agile in southwestern France but the
plague did not rest pierre and
Nostradamus his own words is a vivid
description of a common sight at that
time among the most admirable things I
saw was a woman who even while I was
calling to her through the window
replied to what I was saying while
sewing herself unaided into her own
shroud starting with the feet she was
later found dead in the middle of the
house with her sewing half finished
in 1534 Nostradamus his own wife and
children died presumably of the plague
while he was on a medical mission in
Italy in addition to being a personal
tragedy this was a blow to his own
reputation of a plague doctor which
caused him to fall out of favor with
both the community and his patron
[Music]
in the years following the death of his
family Nostradamus started to move away
from medicine and towards occult
practices most notably astrology and
divination according to legends which
unfortunately is all we have in 1538 he
was forced to leave France after a brush
with the Inquisition during his travels
in Italy he came across a young
Franciscan friar named Philippe she in
France of whom he immediately knelt down
years later the friar was to become Pope
Sixtus v Nostradamus also journeyed
across Greece and Turkey picking up more
occult knowledge and experiencing a
psychic awakening in 1547 he returns
Provence in the town of salon and
married a rich widow named and pond
Sartre the two would go on to have six
children together it was around this
time the Nostradamus really got into
what made him famous his predictions he
would bring upon himself a State of
Trance by meditating for hours in front
of a bowl filled with water and herbs or
maybe in front of a mirror the trance
would bring visions and he would
interpret these into predictions in 1550
Nostradamus wrote down for the first
time these prophecies into an almanac a
popular type of book at the time which
included advice for farmers and
merchants for the coming year including
astrological predictions the success of
his almanacs encouraged Nostradamus the
year 1555 saw the publication of his
magnum opus a collection of predictions
divided in centuries or chapters written
in the style of fourth s poems known as
quatrains these quatrains report
Nostradamus visions for the following
2,000 years and are written in a cryptic
style using anagrams metaphors and an
obscure combination of local French
dialects Greek Latin and Italian some of
his predictions famously anticipated
events such as the Great Fire of London
the French Revolution the advent of
Napoleon the rise and fall of Hitler and
the 9/11 terrorist attacks
[Music]
here is what Nostradamus wrote about the
fire of London the blood of the just
will be lacking in London burped up in
the fire of 66 the ancient lady will
topple from her high place many of the
same sect will be killed as is clearly
stating the Fire of 1666 in London the
doctor also gets another detail right
the blood of the just will be lacking
not only was the death toll of the fire
relatively low with only eight deaths
but the calamity also had the positive
effect of killing millions of infected
rats thus eliminating the outbreak of
plague that had ravaged the city in
previous years and now let's move on to
the French Revolution songs chants and
demands will come down from the enslaved
held captive by the nobility in their
prisons at a later date brainless idiots
will take these as divine utterances now
this runs a little bit more open to
interpretation although you find a
reference to a rebellion against
nobility a prison which could be the
Bastille stormed in 1789 and the rise to
power of brainless idiots possibly the
Directorate during the terror Napoleon
also gets one POW a lauren more far than
blood swimming in praise the great man
hurries to the confluence he will refuse
entry to the Magpies pompon endurance
will confine them the first three words
are an anagram of Nepal and ROI which
sort of sounds like Napoleon the king
who drew his power from military prowess
fire rather than aristocratic origins
blood there is also a vague reference to
Magpies being confined which has been
interpreted to represent Napoleon's
incarcerations of Pope Pius the 6th and
7th Napoleon wasn't the only autocratic
Emperor to be mentioned in the
prophecies see what you make of this one
beasts ferocious with hunger will cross
the rivers the greater part of the
battlefield will be against histah into
a caged van will the great one be drawn
when the son of Germany obeys no law
histor does sound a lot like Hitler plus
you've got Germany in there as well and
you even get a mention of ferocious
beast soldiers or tanks maybe crossing
rivers in numerical superiority on a
battlefield the great one being Hitler
again will be prisoner in a cage of iron
which could be the bunker where he
eventually committed suicide and finally
there's Nostradamus
of the 9/11 attacks in the City of God
there will be a great thunder two
brothers torn apart by chaos while the
fortress endures the great leader will
succumb the third big war will begin
when the big city is burning
two brothers torn apart the twin towers
the enduring fortress the Pentagon which
collapsed only partially and a third big
war on terror to begin straight after I
mean could it be any clearer less
properties has not been out of print
since its first publication but the book
that solidified Nostradamus as celebrity
status was treaty on makeup and jams
this is where he published the plague
remedy I mentioned earlier as well as
recipes for candied orange peel and
cherry preserve but the real treat is
the love jam the ingredients for this
concoction included ingredients found in
every larder nowadays including cinnamon
cloves wind the blood of seven male
sparrows and the tentacles of an octopus
preserved in honey all of the bare
essentials but what was this for it's a
quote if a man were to have a little of
it in his mouth and while having it in
his mouth kissed a woman or a woman him
and expelled it with his saliva putting
some of it in the other's mouth it would
suddenly cause a burning of her heart to
perform the love act and just to be
clear we had by graphics do not endorse
this as a method of wooing a lady
Nostradamus has Fame it grew and he
attracted the attention of some VIP
admirers such as Queen Catarina de
Medici wife to King Henry the seconds
and real power behind the scenes of
French politics Nostradamus had hinted
at some threats to her family in his arm
and accent so the Queen summoned him to
court appointing him counselor and
physician in ordinary to the court in
1556 while serving in this capacity
Nostradamus clarified to her another
prophecy from centuries one which
referred to King on reap century one
quatrain 35 the young lion will overcome
the older one on the field of combats in
a single battle he will pierce his eyes
through a golden cage two wounds made
one then he dies a cruel death despite
being warned by Nostradamus to avoid
jousting matches three years later King
honoré then died 41 years old
facing a younger Knight in a duel his
opponents Lance pierced the Kings visor
shape
as a cage and then entered his brain
behind the eye after ten agonizing days
the king died of sepsis
[Music]
nostradamus the doctor unfortunately did
not possess the knowledge to treat the
ailment which cursed him for much of his
adult life and I was the gout the
condition progressed into dropsy which
is an excessive retention of fluids that
accumulate in body cavities causing
heart failure when it gets extreme in
late of June 1566 Nostradamus called for
his lawyer to draft his last will and
testament to the benefit of his wife and
children on the evening of July the 1st
he told his secretary you will not find
me alive at sunrise this was yet another
accurate prophecy the morning after his
secretary found Nostradamus lying dead
next to his bed
Nostradamus greatest legacy is of course
his prophetic body of work which
continues to puzzle and fascinate
scholars and enthusiasts of the occult
worldwide who strive to interpret is
more obscure writings with by graphics
we want to play our part too and so we
will try to find the hidden meaning
behind the recently discovered quatrains
which foreshadow an apocalyptic future
here is one that will translate for you
in the year 19 the earth is tired a
hammer of darkness shall fall like a
plague this perhaps a reference to the
Spanish flu epidemic of 1919 or maybe
was writing about 2019 from the hands of
the Prince of thousand silver windows so
a windows may refer to mirrors or
screens a thousand screens maybe the
Internet's and who is the prince of
screens who caused this disaster by
wielding the hammer of darkness later
alone and King among the rubble he will
laugh the prince becomes the King's sole
survivor among the destruction but who
that's him
long tsetse fly which is French for the
Whistler
alright Lise I hope you're still
watching and you're not too spooked by
our little prank here let me reassure
you that there are only 12 centuries
published in the prophecies and no cual
trains were recently discovered in
Montpellier I just wanted to make a
point on how easily in recent years the
Internet has fostered just
unsubstantiated interpretations of
Nostradamus predictions or in some cases
they've just circulated quatrains that
were completely made-up
take that famous vision of the 9/11
attacks which I read earlier that
prophecy total fake made up by a
Canadian website to show how easily the
public can be fooled into believing such
predictions funnily enough it was copy
and pasted across
to the web and it's still today believed
by many to be genuine but the wild
interpretation of Nostradamus writing
star for sensationalistic effect can be
traced back to earlier years the famous
histor quatrain was popularized by the
book the prophecies of Nostradamus by
Erekat Cheatham published in 1965 but
her translation from ancient French in
English is either genuinely inaccurate
or manipulated on purpose the word
histor in the 16th century referred to
the lower danube region not to a person
the French originally contains the word
gem Mane which Cheatham translates as
German but a more common meaning of the
word in French was first cousin or
brother in fact here is another
translation of the same prediction by
James Randi the famous Canadian stage
magician and debunker of psychics beasts
mad with hunger will swim across rivers
most of the army will be against the
lower danube the great one should be
dragged in an iron cage when the child
brother will observe nothing which may
refer to any number of engagements
during the 30 Years War the siege of
Vienna by the Ottomans or a lot bunch of
other stuff but as you may expect
prophesizing about World War two
that's just far more exciting to
conclude we don't need to go in doubt
all of Nostradamus errs work mostly
because that would just be really boring
sure most of his predictions they are
vague they are obscure they're
impossible to decipher or they're really
open to exploitative interpretations and
he probably just made everything up to
sell books however it is a fact that
some of them do sort of contain accurate
depictions of what was then his future
our point is that you should always be
skeptical about what you read on the
Internet so I really hope you found that
video interesting a little bit of a
weird one today if you didn't like it
give us a thumbs up below I'd love to
know what you think in the comments
sections below so hit those up and tell
me how I'm doing
also watch some stuff from our archive
if you want to there's some links to all
the videos on the screen and I'll see
you next time
[Music]